and huh yeah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to pray moon
crash now this is the new DLC for pray
and it just came out last week and I
want to play it it's actually different
than a lot of DLC would be that you
would think apparently I I don't know a
lot about it but it says here that
repeated runs through an ever-changing
simulation of the Pythias moon base
which was talked about in the original
pray game a lot each run will present
new combinations of enemies hazards and
loot you might die a lot which doesn't
seem likely for me because there's no
way that I could die when I'm playing
this game but you'll also grow stronger
and unlock new characters and gear to
face these challenges so hello yes we're
live yes we are we are absolutely live
and I have been away for a little bit I
wasn't posting videos this weekend
because I was busy taking care of some
other non video related stuff that uh I
I would I would tell you about what I'm
trying to see if it works out first
before I give too many details about it
but you guys should know about it pretty
soon whether or not it works out or not
but I was busy this weekend but now I'm
back and I've got tons and tons and tons
of cool games I've been recording like
non-stop I've been recording like crazy
but I've just been taking my sweet-ass
time trying to get stuff to you because
I'm a lazy [ __ ] and I'm not a good
youtuber but here I am and here you are
so let's get into this so we're gonna
give it a few minutes here if you're
watching this in the far-flung future
just know that you can skip ahead in the
vaad a few minutes and we'll get started
here but I'm just going to start out
right here and talk to you guys and let
people get in here turtles breathe 74%
of them oxygen through their [ __ ]
so do i I guess we're not so different
after all
hey guys doing yes I'm playing it yes I
am absolutely playing it I'm doing the
thing I am doing the thing yeah oh and
watch out night BOTS been going on a
rampage lately I don't know his his
settings are super weird or her his or
her settings are super weird that bot
has been smashing people down faster
than than I know so just uh don't spam
and don't be all caps like don't be all
don't be all over the place and you'll
you'll be just fine will you do monthly
charity livestreams um I I did monthly
charity livestreams every month from
November of 2016 to November of 2017 and
one of the things that I liked about
that was it made it very consistent and
it made it gave us something to look
forward to but the one thing that I
didn't like about it is that it made it
made it very it made it very unspecial
in a way like it was nice to do charity
livestreams every month and i i vastly
encouraged this and i was talking about
this on Twitch the other day
but the the thing I want to do about
charity events is I want to make them
really really special unified occasions
like one of the ideas is like the
charity calendar that I did the tasteful
nudes calendar that was an interesting
thing that wasn't like a charity
livestream but it raised a ton more
money than a charity livestream ever did
it raised about half a million dollars
over half a million dollars actually for
charities so I want to do things like
that not necessarily a calendar but
things that are special that are
different that are weird because I'm
special different and weird but but
things we're not only we're raising
money for charity because yeah research
does need money and I would always
encourage you guys to give money to
great causes whether it's research or
just helping out like homeless or or
helping out like people that are less
fortunate like I always encourage money
going to those charities if you can give
but also I want to organize events where
we just go out and maybe plant some
trees like I think that'd be really cool
or I encourage people to go out and
volunteer in their local community
because there's always occasions where
you can help out whether it's like your
local school or a hospital or or
something to that effect a homeless
shelter a soup kitchen whatever it is
like
you can go out there and you can help in
your communities and I want to create
events where people realize that not
only are there things that you can do in
your local community but they can spread
this benefit and belief that everyone
can pitch in and help because there's in
the age of the internet there's so many
figureheads like me shouting at you to
help out one cause or another and it can
be super overwhelming but at the end of
the day sometimes the the place where
you can help the most is just with the
people around you with a neighbor like
asking asking your neighbor if they need
their their lawn mowed at some point is
is just a huge benefit or or or helping
out like someone I know it's cliche but
just like helping how big some would
cross the street or something I don't
know like just lend a hand to your
neighbor and it can do the world a lot
of good and so that's what I want to
look forward to in terms of like charity
events in the future I want to I want to
cry and it kind of create things that we
can really you know see a tangible
benefit from and not that money to
charity isn't a tangible benefit but
it's it's very ethereal and it's very
asking a lot of you guys it's always
like hitting up for money every month
and I'm like oh man I don't always want
to do that because people can't always
give or people don't have like money to
give or sometimes I ask you guys and you
guys don't have money to give and you
give anyway and that's really
heartwarming that you do but also I want
to make sure that I want to make sure
that we also spread good in other ways
that aren't just donations to charity so
that's my new that's my new like
philosophy for this upcoming year and
yes my birthday is coming soon okay
that's 9:02 let's do this I don't know
what's gonna be different about this but
this is the moon that they talked about
in the main game they did talk about
that also I've completely forgotten how
to play pray so if I'm bad and I was bad
when I was playing it before but if I'm
bad now don't blame me I've just been
playing too much fortnight and I'm gonna
try to build a fort if some minute comes
after me mmm airless duties
this is basilisk two Cosmo module 13 we
are sending two classified pieces of
technology covered from Tron stars moon
base they should be arriving in a few
moments it's a simulation of all the
research data company secrets okay
station there's a I'm sending you so you
can check them off as you go
congratulations
I am executing these orders contract
after you we're going to pick you up
[Music]
okay all right I'm standing hello shove
it in my eyes that's what you said I
needed to do am I looking the wrong way
I'm gonna look in the right way this
where it is
shove it I'm looking oh there it is
alright okay how do I pick F okay okay F
got okay I totally nailed that I totally
did that exactly as I was gonna do LG
visor to better than VR whoa so this is
what they meant by simulation uh-oh
let me take a shower go to toilet first
my hands and take a shower No okay
alright then let me read this email
before I get to it this is a friendly
reminder operative shall diligently
pursue to the company's reasonable
satisfaction completion of the data
acquisition in accordance with the
contract schedule failure to meet the
satisfaction will extend said contract
for a duration equal to time loss by the
company plus reasonable damages and/or
penalties such damages and penalties are
not eligible for arbitration please keep
in mind that as we move forward to the
end of the contract with Cosmo Corp I
know you're looking forward to seeing
your family again and a setback at this
point would be unfortunate what do they
have my family kidnapped
what kind of stupid day is this Gratz
nice work up there despite the cost
we've dispatched a delivery to you
including a flower from your wife's
garden back home everyone appreciates
your hard work including me
you're really chipping away at that
contract ably okay well that's good I
dug ass alright is this the flower it's
so nice it's so nice let me just throw
it up to my bunk don't tell my wife
don't tell my wife do not tell my wife
okay the rise of corporations discussed
in the new in such books as pure evil by
Tracy Webb and your number is up by Jan
Johansen discuss many challenges to
humanism in a world driven by profit
what even these social scientists didn't
see coming was a new way of collective
bargaining based on relinquish innate
human rights in exchange for better
benefits Wade's pensions and lifestyles
a trend in employee contracts especially
among exciting high-profile companies
like Transtar now onboarding on board
recruits via enticements and
compensation offered nowhere else but
the clause is lurking in these contracts
provide the punitive benefit debts which
an employee must pay the company should
he or she failed to meet the plan this
can lead to a state of indentured
servitude which the contract gags the
employee from discussing and prohibits
arbitration against oh good that sounds
lovely
alright well I'll see you soon family or
not so let's do it
okey-dokey dinner oh there was a book
over there that I didn't read damn it
alright so this is what it means you go
in and you you experience like other
people's memories from scans of their
brain just like you did in the main game
of the
it was revealed and if you didn't whoa I
don't want to be this guy uh uh I don't
want to be this guy he's got magic hands
and I don't remember there being magic
hands and Riis's mind is brimming with
psychic potential waiting to be unlocked
the repeat exposure tuner Aman
technology has left his body frail as
the last volunteer test subject on the
Pythias moon base
Andrea's hopes to escape and see his
young son again all right man I still
don't want to be him you know I I'm good
can I get another locked okay this guy's
locked oh this guy's locked this lady's
locked the janitor and Joan Winslow all
right well let's do this let's do this
he's not ugly oh don't call him ugly oh
come on now oh you don't know what to
say well that's fair enough neither do i
yeah okay I don't know what this is
gonna do for me but uh we're gonna try
it
space race begins with both the US and
Soviet Union make arrival announcements
about their intent to launch the first
satellite okay all right okay thank you
yeah
hey man love your channel in your work
you're pretty awesome yourself man great
work and praise my favorite playthrough
well thank you so much and I I really
enjoyed prey when I was playing through
it it was I I haven't played like a long
let's play in a long time mostly just
because I've been doing videos where
everything is like super dense or it's
like a full game in one video and I
haven't had a I haven't had the
wherewithal or the emotional readiness
to challenge myself with doing a 12 hour
let's play in a single video and I know
I could break it up into multiple
sessions but then working on it
we're unable to reach an escape pod
security will track your position as
they conduct a final sweep before
launching gravity's real low alright
okay
unlock okay Cooper
submix I remember how to beat your ass
oh hey whoa wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa I'm tired I'm tired now okay I
miss somehow special all right you've
got whomped you got whomped good i
remember how to lump you guys think I
don't know how to womp
oh I remember oh I remember all right
well I remember deeply how to womp
okay Typhon gate information use the
station to monitor and track nearby
Typhon well that's handy dandy that's
handy dandy Randy okay good now how did
I that's how you get to the weapons
how did Duty hop it did to doodie how
did I have powers I I know I have powers
here we go okay neuro Mons that's what
I'm looking for
oh I don't have powers yet I thought you
said this guy was blooming you said this
guy was brimming with with psychic
potential use hands were glowing like in
the beginning you you saying he doesn't
have it yet you said repeat exposure
fine alright it's all in your head
escape with the volunteer through the
mimic portal to unlock this mission
let's do this I don't have psychic
powers yet but you best believe your
whump and ass I'm gonna have it soon can
I breathe out here is this oh cool oh
this is cool
now you do his cool well like it reminds
me of dead space mines me deeply of dead
space hello down there
Murray mimics oh it's a dead body okay
well not what I was thinking
Oh take that thanks for the moolah
nothing in there all right okay you're
coming with me I'm gonna throw you at a
Hannah Typhon the second I see it all
right
you're forgot
silly the rag doll was all right done no
no no lady left behind here we're all a
team we're all part of the same the
ecosystem oh there's a very dead guy
over there okay well you're uh who was
your name again
Mandy all right Mandy all right listen
Mandy you're gonna be fine everything's
gonna be good we're gonna get out of
here and we're gonna survive because
that's how we do what happened to this
guy what happen to you yeah yeah he's
seen better days
he's only marginally less ugly than I am
so to be perfectly honest he's uh he's a
bit more handsome so uh maybe I should
take him in it's too uh Benjamin Ben Ben
all right Ben all right Mandy you stay
there I got you in the shade you're not
gonna get a sunburn now so um
me and Ben me and Ben we're we're just
gonna go here I saw like a glowy up here
there was something hello hello okay
explosive canister sounds nice all right
explody you're with me now Ben you can
suck a dick I I don't even want to deal
with you right now
all right fine Ben guy you're coming
with me you're coming with me Ben
you're coming with me all right so we
got to find whatever the hell we're
supposed to be doing there's it says
there's a crater over there but I'm not
a hundred percent sure if that means I'm
supposed to go over there
means that I'm gonna do whatever I got
OS that's probably not good
whoops nothing to do that Oh Ben keep
your head on us all
Ben you better keep your head on a
swivel all right explody it's your time
to shine huh
go get him exploding go get him get him
hmm well that didn't work
that's not oh you're stuck in your stall
pin the tail on the one pole all right
well I'm not gonna get your materials
but that's okay all right all right
exploding it's your time to shine if I
remember this correctly these are these
explode after a time yep yep they do yep
yep whoa ha ha got ya womp womp inch one
Paul Biscay I remember this oh you think
you gonna get away right you did you
away from the once I'm physically frail
you're losing to a physically frail guy
who what how does that make you feel
loser okay all right that worked out
well come on Ben we got places to be we
got people to see we got we got we got
mimics to whump come on
there's Typhon in need of one pitch over
here get Gate bypass improper use can
severe injury or death hmm well all
right hang on all right Ben you're gonna
test this out for me you're always
willing to test stuff right no no no no
good right in the gap right in the gap
yeah stick your head in there as close
skit just gone Kate get your head in
there okay good good right that's good
okay hold still
[Music]
deadly activation in three two well that
didn't do jack [ __ ] what what that
didn't it Ben Ben you all right you all
right Ben all right ban you're coming
with me
who new friend Oh oxygen okay good thing
I don't need it apparently hey what's
your name how you doing
yo.hannes good thanks for the shotty
Shruti Thank You Johanna s-- but uh to
be honest I don't think we're gonna be
good friends I'm gonna stick with Ben
here all right Ben let's do this
we're going I don't need a tutorial on a
shotgun what kind of what kind of
scrublord do they think I am
Oh new friend I don't know if it's gonna
be better than Ben though Ben is just
the best friend and I know Ben might be
slowing me down to a crawl but what did
I say about not leaving people behind
all right who's this your name's note
yeah
that's not right that's horrible
why do we have a tentacle grenade is
this a hand tie bomb is that what this
is cuz I'm not about that I mean these
mimics and Typhon have tentacles already
but this is just this ain't good all
right anyway what's your name Michael
Chung okay until those kill towers are
working Typhon lawyers are still our
best bet for drawing them away from the
gates I already put in a wreckin for the
lab techs to fab more V bhatia okay well
that's not you so why did you have that
Ben I don't know what's going on here
there's a lot of weird stuff happening
on the moon it's just a place a sexual
deviancy as far as the eye can see who
knew who knew all right okay what's this
Oh an EMP charge why is this so amazing
when I picked this stuff up Ben Ben do
they think I don't know what this is all
about because Ben I really do I really
do Ben you asked me anytime you ask me
anytime I know what's going on here I'm
well aware
oh the ins and outs of what's happening
here
okay Pythias lab crew annex moon works
is that like game works but on the moon
okay wait no if the moon is a place of
sexual deviancy i don't know if i want
to go to the game work so that ah you
know what nothing ventured nothing
gained I might as well go explore right
Ben you you're you're probably you are
probably into some sick and twisted [ __ ]
just judging by the look on your face
when I found you
yeah I know a look of ecstasy when I see
it oh that's probably not gonna be good
don't trust put bend down put bend down
whoo I never I never imagined I can't
believe you put bend down are you out of
your gourd what has been never done to
you oh yeah okay now that we got that
out oh I can't even go to the moon works
it's protected by magic
some kind of magic goopy I can't beat
squares that's for damn sure so there's
no way that I'll be able to beat them
see me carrying been around means that I
don't get snuck up on come on don't
don't no you don't want to see me look
oh you're seeing me Hey look listen I'm
very hidden
hi Ben the jig's up Ben I got the jig's
up okay all right then we got that well
sorted where's uh where uh didn't it
drops up all right whoa you're not dead
yet oh I could have whomped you we could
have whomped you I I did you a service
by shooting you all right Ben you
watched my back wall Ben watch out watch
out Ben Ben watch out oh good move spend
good moves Ben
I bet let's go come on Ben we gotta get
in this what if we hit one of these and
throw it at him
good idea Ben all right we're gonna want
this oh we can't carry never it's been
whooped I didn't know that whoa
see ya see ya okay Ben he didn't want to
mess with us he saw I was crazy enough
to hit an explosive canister right at my
feet there ain't no way he's gonna
tussle with the likes of me it's just
full of he's back he's back man he's
back you come back to the break room
[ __ ] all right okay all right dying
that you died but you died but don't
fret dying is an expected part of
exploring the base simulation if you
have four crew members available you can
continue exploring where you left off
otherwise the simulation will reset and
you can start a new run progress you've
made such as earning some points and
finding fabrication plans is always
preserved all right running straight
into the I don't know that running into
the guy wouldn't happen
maybe maybe standing mirror
whoa give me that [ __ ] oh so many
puppets
give me some anti rad - I mean I'll need
anti rad for how rad I'm gonna be when I
get back in here
I like this oh I like this oh I like
this all right I got to find Ben again
it better be bad it better not be no
randomly generated names could have
Ben's not there I'm gonna be so sad my
fiance and I have been watching you for
a very long time and love what you do
could you give Alex G a small shadow
well shoutout to Alex G thank you so
much for being here
I'm so funny no that was a little Bob
I'm just an idiot shouting at the void
and put here like I don't know why but
for some reason just my unintentional
demise there really really got to me
okay oh yeah my health was low I forgot
that the blue bar at the bottom left is
my health okay Terry Brown I'm gonna
assume that that was you and I'm gonna
assume that Ben's okay my elite shooting
skills you're done zoo you're done zone
man shotgun shells oh yeah please all
right let's do this
all right we're going hard on this hello
are you the same as you were can I have
your stuff all right cool all right
let's do this
Ben Ben he's waiting for him please be
Ben if you're not Ben I'm gonna be so
sad Ben it's you it's really you
Ben I've missed you Ben I can't believe
it's really you
all right well I've got plenty of this
but honestly who gives a [ __ ] I've got a
pistol ass at Lance pistol all right
well uh I definitely don't know that
there's some no maybe if they actually
hit it no hmm there's another town in
the area I know there was one more crack
him whoa all right cool rock my friend
all right Ben we're off let's do this
Ben come on Ben
Hey look he's reaching out to me Oh get
out of it how could you leave a face
like that behind
oh you leave a face like alright then
you know it's better off if you're
behind me because then I don't have to
look at you been
alright but we got this I can't oh no I
didn't leave I would never leave Ben you
should go leave been uh
been my Ben you think I would leave Ben
behind my buddy Ben my bit me me me
hombre van you think I'd leave Ben his
middle name is buddy
it's Ben buddy friend oh that's his name
you don't leave a guy like that behind
Johannes Cruz yeah you leave you leave
you a nice fine easily come on come on
dad come on don't be shy come on all
right we gotta give that security
workstation then we got to not die when
we do it so that's probably pretty
important I like the leisurely stroll of
it too because it lets me take in the
environment now this is a pretty
environment all right Michael yeah I
don't really care what about Michael
I only care about so also I distinctly
have kind of a memory that the I
distinctly remember that the the
servitor things or whatever they are
they kind of they do blow up a little
bit I don't have a face on it
is that a face am i seeing some right
there right right on the bottom at the
blue is that a face you got a face oh no
that's your ass oh do you have enough
face on your ass that's really cool I
wish I had to face with my ass I think
I'll get a dad too
it looks like a face oh it looks like
he's going oh whoa was that guy Korean
been around you know I don't know look
it's a face oh he's just always
surprised ah that's so cute you're cute
oh he's vaping - oh that's adorable
okay - tower what does that even mean
what is it what won't a Typhon tower be
that's where I that's where I died what
the hell is a Typhon tower
hmm that doesn't make any sense at all
okay hello I hear something doesn't seem
good you know anything about this Ben
come on Ben come on what they've spotted
me Ben hang on
whoa I forgot they shoot laser beams
then that was a close one good duck on
that one
you really know how to dodge those laser
blasts all right Ben we got to make
through this let's loot and let's keep
moving I didn't think that I would be
able to get like 300 bullets from the
get-go I don't even think I had three
hundred bullets ever in my original
playthrough I never had that many
bullets so I think I'm gonna get through
this just fine all right wait what
security workstation okay it must be
down here right all right all right then
then you watch the door okay I'm gonna
leave you with let's see you can have
this one per you take this one let's how
do I drop dirt X all right Ben you take
that one per all right oh yeah bond it
to you with your blood okay you take
that you guard the door
I'll be back don't worry I wouldn't
leave without ya okay anyway I've lost
my hentai bomb I'm real sad about that I
mean not that I'd use it or anything but
you know if I was curious at all I'd
probably use it maybe I mean I'm not
saying I would but I'm I'm not opposed
to it am I looking at odhh turret
I forgot you could hide in things
stupid-ass office all right well anyway
security workstation who are you talkin
Auto Oh
TACA TACA that looks like the face of a
friend right there that's a friendly
face that is a friendly as face that
better not that better not auto attack
me okay dad is a friendly face a target
are you doing you know this place around
here you know this place huh you can
tell me hmm all right you keep it a
secret use a Z okay what are we looking
for
no life signs no life signs Johannes
Cruz I already found you Hannes I don't
need to know I don't I already know
where Johannes is no you're already
Johannes is right he's outside
it's not really important crew annex no
no oops no that's not what I wanted no
that's not what I wanted either
how do I scroll down in this oh this no
moon works era body dude era but it did
who everybody did okay yeah no I don't
need that okay I don't know who I'm
looking for
but uh I don't think that's gonna help
me at all all right what's my next
objective here honestly I don't know
let's just explore this place glue I
forgot about the glue where's my goo
where's my goo gun oh please please I've
been waiting for my goo oh please let me
through if I had my goo gun can I want
this why can't I want this where's uh
where's my Whomper can I move this to my
wampa CH how do I do that a 101 plomp
okay
all right let's see if there's another
way help
yeah well I am supposed to go to the
security workstation what are you what
are you doing then what am I supposed to
do with you utilities that's right
reveal
I'm dumb I'm real dumb I'm real dumb
okay engineering annex over there stairs
that leads off to another area but
that's closed off - okay all right
escape pod status check status crater
pod available okay well that's nice
power radiation nominal oxygen nominal
fire hazards no fire too much this is
nice well this is uh trams even
operational supply status okay what does
this mean engineering addicts trauma
center storage room trouble ah don't do
that Oh coming through whoever told you
this place was a place with sexual
deviancy well what is this okay where's
my fabricator machine I want to throw
all my junk in okay command module so I
need to find command modules is that
what I need or do I just need to escape
because I'll escape
I'll run huh I am NOT above running like
a little [ __ ] baby I will I will gladly
Oh black Hey
oh this is where radiation is okay well
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't have glue to put that out here's
a lot of a lot of goop here alright well
here at least is the fabricator machine
so I can't I don't want to make anything
just yet I want to place items in the
bin all right ah transfer junk get it
out of here okay alright dude where's
Ben okay
wait is this EU skate pod where's Ben
Ben Ben Ben are you making a break for
it bed without me
you better not then Ben you better not
thank you better huh he better be I know
there's no way Ben wouldn't do me like
that Ben is there anything here that I
actually need or is this just okay
subject Thunder crater 1459 low light
conditions initial movement is tentative
and uncertain remains near airlock for
five minutes decides to cross grader at
1505 presumably to check out their
airlocks Typhon notice the subject
approximately 10 meter from airlock
subjects expires moments later due to
standard attack via mouth an airway I
told you this moons a place of sexual
deviancy subject Anders crater 10:23
light conditions good subject rests on
haunches with back against wall one
meter from airlock subject does not move
for approximately one hour remains
unnoticed at 11:37 small Typhon arrives
at airlock Teske at Typhon gate notices
subject subject expires moment later
that's weird
okay whatever all right I'm gonna go
find Ben I think I got everything that I
need from here I think it's just like
the only objective is to go to the
airlock but there's probably gonna be
something when I get over there that's
like you can't get in the airlock it's
just your bunch up but yes can you
believe it what is there something
actually through that that I need to
know about no I can't I can't do it it's
too it's too big I'm - I'm - half oh
there we go okay now I just go through I
don't know why that's necessary but it
is apparently probably for those
randomly generated run aah Ben Ben
ever-vigilant
oh don't worry I'll take that for you
all right Ben we got to get to the
escape pod I got a way out Ben Ben I got
the way out we can get off this rock
don't worry Ben I'd never leave you
behind just like I know you'd never
leave me behind even though I was
worried about it for a second and I
thought you would left me behind
I knew I knew Oh baby I knew you
wouldn't leave me behind and together
we're gonna get it we're gonna get out
of here hello Harvester a what are you
heart what what are you harvesting
harvesting like organs blood
maybe all right okay don't look at me
with that face all right I think we're
gonna be good I could heal but I'm only
ten health points down so I think I'm
okay mmm got to find a womp Bom warning
this video will make you laugh Adam I
don't know about that I don't know this
video this video is gonna make you cry
with how emotional our journey is
together that I don't want to clear the
area
I don't trust you Oh what happened to
your face that's weird
okay hello all right then we're almost
there just stay low
that's Uncle Jim always said you just
gotta stay low I thought I thought that
was a robot that was gonna be like
disintegrates just shinik right but alas
it was not Oh Ben I found it more I
found a more efficient method of
transportation Ben this look wear it
Batman bad ban ban ban now look Ben we
he's jumping for joy can you believe it
man we're almost there
he can't contain his his excitement this
skateboard wahoo
[Laughter]
Oh Ben come on you got it can't be can't
be he - you're just you're gonna draw
attention to us is that a banger nope
okay all right man
I can't contain it whoa oh hello hi Liza
how are you doing is that a neuroma
oh hell yeah what I don't wanna
oh okay all right
what is this kinetic blast I like that
that is right up my alley
i'ma go with kaneto blast I'm gonna do
that oh yeah shove it in my eye
oh yeah swing swing oh yeah
yeah yeah I don't care how cool it is
this is no war that's not good bad look
out never mind
some powers are trickled instantly by
pressing Mouse to some powers are
targeted stop time and enter site
targeting mode personal most two mounts
to aim release Mouse 2f to cancel okay
all right we got this who's there who's
there man do you see anybody Liza I'm
sorry go away alright here we go
oh hey how's it going sure would be a
shame if somebody able to pull up the
entire no-no-no Typhon detected that's
weird about that hmm okay alright well
Ben will you and me buddy
you and me buddy right to the end you
and me buddy I'm so proud of you and I'm
so proud of myself
Ben so happy that we could be here
together this is like you know we been
through we've been through so much
damn maybe I shouldn't have done all
that fire but then you know how it is I
get carried away all the time what's
down there
well there's a path down Ben well bet
Ben Ben don't scare me like that Ben
don't ever leave me like that
Oh terrified Ben what's terrified we're
going down Ben okay all right you're so
stealthy Ben thump flunk slap the
governor I never was good at these
chipset things put it in put it in shove
it in shove it shove it in just shove it
anywhere just shove hard shove it in
I can't shove I'm trying to shut it's
not letting me shove there we go
I don't know why suddenly it let me
shove but I was trying to shove I really
was shoving as hard as I could shove but
I got it
alright let's eat one of these victory
you want to ration hi Ben you want Ben
you want some food don't worry Ben I got
you
Ben I got you Ben you eat up you eat up
buddy
there you go alright I'll turn away I
know I know you don't like to be watched
when you're eating ok eating's up
alright let's go Ben we're so close
this can't pause right over there we
just gotta get out of here alive we can
do this Ben we're so close alright then
you're gonna have to jump for it good
job Ben wow that was a nice jump all
right no Typhon around here alright
let's do this
yeah hello hello um hello hello okay man
this reminds me well Ben you heard that
you heard the news time to make the
bacon
uh yeah get oh you you don't want none
of this
oh do you oh I think he wants some of
this I think he might want some of this
he seems got it tough it's histoy desk
what am i oh what am I looking at he's
in school Ben all right you watch the
door I always count on you to watch my
back all right come here you bastard you
want to mess with me you know you can
mess with me but if you even try to mess
with Ben Mon hey douche no no no no no
no no no I don't like that you try to
mess with Ben you're gonna get the horns
boom oh and this why are you gonna do
one damage seems like it should do more
than one to zero oh he's mad zero that's
a that's a number zero oh um I usually I
like more than zero when my numbers bath
oh hey whoa hey let's talk about this
here
let's just let's chitchat this guy's not
happy Oh what what what sexual deviancy
I told you was a place ascetical hell oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god huh I don't like that no no no no
no there we go
weapons malfunction out of there can you
please oh oh oh why please can you
please fix yourself how do I fix little
wait how do I fix this huh how do i his
what what do i what what do I do
what what do i what do I do well
whatever it's not fit I don't remember
how to fit how do you repair ok Plan B
you know how to be sneaky right well
we're about to be the sneakiest smokiest
we've ever been I know we were exploding
up the entire area and there's a
tentacle that's looking at as real funny
we're gonna get out of here okay
not leavin without you get in there you
better be with me Ben Ben's not with me
okay pens with me we gotta go okay
Oh low profile
all right okay bad
that's a tentacle nest so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to shoot it one bullet
at a time that's a lot of type one but
they're all downstairs Ben got this
Ben you and me you and me oh that that
seems like this that seems like that
should not be like that
oh okay all right Ben I'm gonna eat some
udon noodles and then uh I'm gonna kiss
my ass curb uh-oh here we go sorry I
blow that's what I was looking for how
do i how do I make that uh can i how do
I make that into a
okay how do i how do I find that to
something uh easy to use ah well that's
fine whoa I don't know what this is but
good time to look at it yep definitely a
good time to look at it oh I got it I
got him Ben you got him I didn't do it
my weapon was jammed Ben Ben you did it
you did it
I knew that chest-mounted shotgun was
gonna be good oh man and I was saying it
was silly Huw man you always know okay
Ben you wait here I trust you you're not
gonna take that you're not gonna take
the escape pod and run off without me I
know I know you well alright well good
thing I missed good thing there's a
tentacle there all right let's let's go
get in bed let's go get him okay we're
just gonna blow up that tentacle right
down
okay that's good okay just uh okay EBU
blow up anyway he blew up himself
boys you played yourself good it's okay
one bullet at a time it's all I need
when you got aim this good you don't
even need to know about how to shoot
okay last one oh come on that was right
oh I did it
dad dad we're gonna do it
ban ban you and me buddy you and me
buddy you and me buddy Ben you and me
you in first hang on you in first okay
this better not because it's better just
open the door okay that just opens it
okay Ben are you me Benny are getting
you first go oh come on no I know you
want to stay but go get it Ben get in
there don't go in hoarse you're like a
dog trying to bring a stick that's too
big indoors Ben please just get in there
we go pin all right strapped in tight
Ben we're going baby we're out of here
Ben Benny boy you and me have been
through a lot together
we're about to get yachty
you me been bent body you me you me it's
Jimmy
it's you me Ben you me you me Ben no
congratulations you escape the Pythias
moon base with one's Transtar crewmember
eventually you want to unlock all five
and discover all five escape routes
escaping more than once in the same run
yields increasingly larger simple
rewards your ultimate goal is to escape
with all crew members in one go without
resetting the simulation good luck okay
on to the next one we unlock the
engineer Oh am i doing beyond that what
do you mean
reminder operative shall diligently no
that's not it not the new one install
the stability track of what what's gonna
happen if what's gonna happen if I go
back in and it's unstable they're gonna
do something to my brain I really I like
my brain my brain drill cool I like it
it's it's my favorite part of me in fact
I mean next to my but of course I really
like I'm real proud of what I got and my
derriere but alright but now we go in
again and then we uh it's gonna get
harder and harder that was easy mode
that was easy mode that was easy mode ok
simulation ready ok that was easy mode
like my toilet paper collection will the
bathroom again be are so fun I love it
it's so fun ok a crash like a train made
of screams running headlong into a
school full of glass children what the
[ __ ] kind of book is this Trevor Pulsar
winced as the deafening sound blinded
him sticky Trevor was sticky and ached
from head to boot oh this is some
rebirth from this wait a minute the star
bender cycled to book one rebirth from
the star I I dove in too fast it's like
when you dive into a pool and you can't
swim I wasn't ready for that
okay back to Trevor was sticky and ached
from head to boot okay where was he how
is he even alive his eyes slowly
adjusted his brain began to lurched then
spin into action because that's how
brains work the dark star anomaly
Empress tourmaline the star bender prism
he remembered term aleene's words as the
galaxy split between them find me pause
I find the prism I love this bow and
read this book as Trevor finally heaved
himself up right what he saw confirmed
his fears a cracked stone tower jutted
against the rolling keep rolling
medieval skies dragons I've been sent
back in time Trevor saw ya back in time
to when dragons wheeled overhead just
basically think like a dragon bit its
tail it is just like spinning like a
cartwheel through the air like it's
beautiful that's a thing of beauty
that's a thing of beauty God I want to
read that book is this different nuts
the same I want to read the book I gotta
read the book that's such a good book
[Music]
good we're going back in now we're gonna
play at the engineer and I imagine
things are gonna get a lot worse
oh man she means business all right Joan
Winslow Joan never met a machine she
couldn't fix her improve and isn't shy
about trying a little impact calibration
on living things especially with the
sort with tentacles Joan can always
summon a friendly turret all right okay
can I get this laser turrets I already
had one of those I guess I got two guns
now I'm not gonna have if I'm not gonna
have a billion laser turrets I'm gonna
have a million guns and you're not gonna
stop me there's no way in hell you you
ain't gonna stop me from having a
million guns I'll have a gun found out
one two three four five to ten I've got
ten guns and so many bullets you you're
gonna regret
you're gonna regret we're gonna regret
the day you didn't let me have a million
turrets you're gonna regret that throw
those in there you're gonna regret
recycle one telepath with your recycler
charge okay all right I don't know what
that means but okay no yeah no one
stopped me from getting what I want
nobody nobody no no no not today
now dude a Ben Ben was Ben was that
other guy's friend Ben Ben's not my
friend my friend are my pistols my ten
pistols I'm gonna name them all we're
gonna have a great time it's gonna be
wonderful
Ben yeah I bet this Joan doesn't care
about Ben Ben Ben is Ben's Ben's a bit
rude you know Ben made some advances
that were unwelcome and and
doesn't want any part of that yeah don't
don't even don't even do that
yeah Ben just not about Ben this kazmo
orders completing all items on the chasm
order checklist will fulfill your
contract with Casper Corp you can be
your progress on the kid nice okay cool
I got bonus objectives um kazmo orders
that's okay well it's basically just do
what I'm doing right okay whatever all
right yeah let's get one two three four
five six seven eight nine and zero all
right okay all right you're you're Larry
you're Jerry you're Mary you're Steve
you're weave your sleeve your johansson
your PO Hanson your mo Hanson and your
Bob okay everybody got that
Jerry Larry Mary Steve sleeve leave
Johansson Poe Hanson MO Hanson and Bob
everybody got that you better remember
it all right we're gonna go with uh go
with Jerry first Jerry
Larry Mary Steve spliffs Cleve Johansson
Poe Anson Melanson Bob all right we're
gonna go with Jerry first my brain my
brain Terry Terry
dad that was another day but too late
don't get in my way all right hey I
gotta go through this again Jerry
Larry Mary Steve no yes Steve sleeve
sleeve Johansen Paul Hanson Moe Hanson
and Bob okay all right all right we got
we got we got we got okay whose whose Oh
someone already got these guys is that a
persistent we're Aldo it's pursue
staining does that mean the wait Bob
wouldn't be here Bob escaped Bob Bob
couldn't possibly be here there's no way
Bob wouldn't see Bob's gone look Bob's
gone Bob made it out Bob free Bob's free
he measured it you hear that hear that
Oh Jerry
Larry Mary Steve spleeb squib
Johanssen plantain Munson and Bob Bob me
Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben made it up
Ben made it out wait what's that over
there I see something I can't believe it
Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben
made it up there I said Ben didn't you
guys hear me say Ben I said Ben okay oh
this is nothing
okay well this is pointless
all right let's go let's go out here all
right Jerry's real hungry for the first
shot I know it Ben made it Ben Ben made
it out yeah Ben Ben did I say Ben or did
I say Bob I met Ben Ben Ben made it up
all right let's do this
whoo all right hey are you going there
their propulsion system oh listen to me
you need to stay off the lunar surface I
repeat do not step foot on the regulate
there's something underneath
I think it's drawn to movement it senses
vibrations I can't kill it
there's a shuttle in crew but we are
stuck in the damn crater until we get
the typhoon gates down round up anyone
else you can find warn them
[Music]
that's probably okay that's probably
okay
all right Jerry how are you feeling
about this one oh no no no no no let's
not do that Larry don't like vibrations
like that that that moon sharp moon oh
maybe that's a bad idea
what the hell what the hell what the
hell Larry don't do that
Larry God listen to your sister Mary I
know Mary I know you told him not to do
that
all right Steve you're up and then leave
and thence cleave johansson pow Anson mo
Hanson and Bob but Steve you're up
Oh feels so good I think I got a
concussion all right let's go out there
let's watch out for the moons those moon
sharks they're a doozy they're a real
doozy dozer they are hey just okay Shawn
under the vibrations
well me and Mike I don't have any oh I
do good common mister shark can I call
you mister noon noon can I call you moon
listen how about you don't
marry Steve don't do it sorry couldn't
resist
alright let's do this alright moon shark
mr. Mooney what are you doing I'm gonna
kill you one hit point out of time
I'm ready to dance all day baby I'm
ready to dance all day what do you think
do you think I'm all about huh
you think I'm one to mess with no you
get out of here you get out of your
don't like that okay Bob money all right
he's going over there I'm he's not going
fast enough
okay so I got to stay off the lunar
surface maybe I could stand on
somebody's corpse somebody's cold dead
corpse oh maybe that would be like some
good news
maybe I could do that okay I don't know
where he is but I have a funny feeling
that I probably shouldn't didn't make a
break for it but I will my weights I
want to see if he goes around the
loop-d-loop because if he goes around
the loop-d-loop then that's gonna be
that's gonna be more more goodly more
goodness for me okay he's I forgot about
this thing anymore I need it so much
more than what you gave me good jump
leap hello how are you doing
Kenz
oh boy okay okay oh this is not where I
want to be let's put a car down good job
Steve good job Steve all right you're up
spleef all right spleef okay show them
how it's done spleef show them how it's
done
put come was your name was her name put
Tamar again oh okay I'm gonna put you
right here put Tamar again I guess okay
you do good I don't know why you're damn
Oh cuz they were exploding all in your
face I I see okay that makes sense that
makes a lot I still have a conclusion
which is no good no bueno
no bueno at all I can't think Oh the
rocks would be fine if I could actually
land on the rocks oh ye oh ye oh ye no
Typhon all around let's go that guy is
terrifying leaves your hero
pretty good in what world in what world
and what ended in what world ow ow in
what world in what world in what in what
world the scared the piss out of me hey
Mark I love it vids you always know how
to make me laugh oh thank you so much as
awesome huh man that's scary me I don't
plan on playing Detroit become human
it's it's just not a game that injures
me that's mainly the reason so I'm gonna
leave that one on its own
so if you guys haven't seen prey I put a
link to the distant Eyre playlist in the
description down below so if you want to
see prey or any of the other videos of
this I don't think this game is gonna
spoil anything but you can check that
out down there I'm so close to death a
medkit at all did I didn't I pick up a
medkit no I thought I'd picked up I
thought I did Oh what happened oh I
can't run well if I run I bleed that's
awful
that's a horrible please somebody help
me I am in so desperate need a better
God nice get it sleep believe you got
him
it's awfully squooshy over there okay
looking for medicine just oh hey hey
buddy
well you know huh this looks like a job
for a job for Bob Bob's coming at ya
can't shoot you through that so I guess
I'm okay
yellow turnips tooless oh I thought that
was turnips I just had like ah ah whoa
okay you can't get through that but
that's good that's a good thing okay
yes please let me have enough to
fabricate just uh Wow is that there's
something in here don't hit me please
give me anything literally I'll take
anything except sacrificing any of my
any of my guns no matter what I do I
will not give up my guns okay place on
all right I don't think there's anything
in here
I really don't okay that's nice escape
pod navigation ship okay do you mean to
tell me that Ben and that other guy
didn't make it because they didn't have
a navigation ship another dead is that
what you're telling me okay probably can
I make okay what does it take for a tear
ash it just takes plant I got I've got
tulips can I throw tulips in there I can
transfer junk uh yeah I could give up
one of my one of my not all of them just
uh yeah one just kind of how do I enter
there we go okay enter
yeah all right recycle it I need to make
some rations because I'm I'm hangry I am
a hankering for how forget that I can't
run I forget I forget that I can't run
okay can I add and greet connect okay
did I not get what I put but what I but
I put enough to get but this is it said
it's gonna get better be enough please
do I have enough oh thank goodness
one ration okay eat that you dis up yum
yum yum I'm all better now
I am all better I am 100% a okay all
right well okay let's look at the emails
okay there's been a small accident
resulting in a chemical spear near my
station it's not as it as to the
industrial cleanup team told me to
contact you
boring daily clean boring play
basketball
okay help briefcase cleanup can you
handle that
I'm hosting a molecular cuisine event
next week and I need your help doing a
deep-clean in my prep space it's just
all people asking for clean I guess this
is the custodial services so that
wouldn't make sense I guess I don't know
it delayed them well representing a
loophole in the system which you may
exploit a temporary slow corruption in
the system oh let's use that slow down
corruption you ain't gonna get me not
today okay I don't have enough space for
that which is just regard damn dick ulis
there's no way that I don't have enough
space so I'm going to drop this cuz die
obviously don't need it okay can I take
this thank you alright I guess I'm gonna
open the gate
I can't run can't do that let's open the
gate
alright Bob you're up Bob
hey got you okay Bob nice sneak attack
why you do know why you do know uh no no
no no uh-uh
Oh Mary Mary Mary oh oh no I'm gonna die
oh no my turret oh this is less than
good all right well I'll just wait for
my turret to come back and oh good
scatting what an accurate record okay
that's good
oh there you are all right well let me
just Mary is out for blood right now
okay I'm gonna grab you you you said
there was nothing that I couldn't repair
you said there was nothing
what about laser turret I know I have
that don't I didn't I buy one laser turn
where's my where my laser my laser
turret is not here I bought a laser
turret oh boy okay well I'm gonna have a
new one eventually
Oh what's it known I mean I mean I mean
okay hmm
okay no Typhon detected are you sure
about that are you sure you're sure you
want two percent sure because I am Not
sure eat that yes please yes oh do you
mean that didn't cure me doc don't like
bleeding out my ass here
alright fine then you're a Warbler okay
your Warbler okay no Typhon detective we
are we're fine we're all fine
everything's fine
take that got drinks there that'll do me
good no I'll get it married okay alright
good job Mary okay but it's this times a
job for Johansen good job Johansen I
feels better
[Music]
silence whistle yeah I donate another
one oh shut up shut up al I'm bleeding
again okay apparently I got hit there is
II don't trust you
oh no no time for glue okay drink organ
oh oh
everything feels wushi all right okay
we're fine
nope can't do it oh yes please can I
have that thank you
and crispy fries okay good good good
okay all right
hoot-hoot a week left I keep doing it
okay
sleeve all right sleeve you're up don't
care Cuban no don't need a QB okay we're
good
this is just too dicey I can't take any
unnecessary risks
good sleeve is really cautious and
that's perfectly understandable cuz you
never know you never know what thought I
saw movement
hello kiss I hypo I don't need that I
don't have any sigh tick that psycho
static cutter what does that even mean
what's a psycho static cutter I don't
know don't trust it don't trust that
trashcan don't trust this chair don't
trust his chair don't touch that flower
don't trust that no chair don't trust no
trust no trust no trust no trust trust
no no trust no trust no trust Trust
trust Trust trust Trust trust Trust
trust all right cliff you're getting a
little out of hand here all right let's
go back to let's go to mo Hanson or you
PO Anson you PO Hanson or mo Hanson Joe
Hanson
Oh handsome your hands and mo Hanson Poe
Hanson I think it was your mo Hanson
you're definitely mo Hanson okay no
dress no trust Trust trust Trust trust
Trust trust no trust no trust no trust
okay we'd like to remind everyone to
please observe the posted quiet hours on
level one of the crew Mannix quality
dressed is essential for peak
performance and safety okay well why
can't I repair this you said that I was
a repair maniac you said that I was so
good at repair you said I was so good
that's what you said that's what you
said ooh somebody in here no trust you
said that I was so good at repair wasn't
I so good at repair wasn't that the
thing about me repairing
can't install neuro mods walk concussed
I got you okay all right that's fine all
right I saw an access point so there's
got to be like uh has got to be some
kind of an access panel that I can go
into that's gonna give me their trust
there's nothing don't trust I don't
trust you so wherever this is I'm gonna
find it
Wow there it is okay this is this is the
access panel right behind here find
these either talking booths or gambling
booze no trust I don't trust I need a
medical operator that's what I need and
last time I remember there might have
been one in like these closed off rooms
no not today
but maybe in neuro mod okay eat I'm a
glutton I'm a glutton I just shove
everything in my god trust no trust
dress dress dress trust no trust trust
dress
no rest rest no trust no no trustee okay
I'm full up on help amazingly I am
stuffed to the brim but I'm still out of
trust no trust no trustee sorry I'm so
paranoid but just I don't want to die
because you get cumulative rewards if
you just if you don't die in between
runs that's what it said I don't trust
those towels the trust was right there
in the locker that's a lot of guys
that's probably not good that probably
dies probably bad I imagine that's I'm
as and it's real bad don't trust no
never trust a towel I hear something
I don't trust you wha-wha found a good
luck
here you but I don't trust you anybody
in the bathroom don't trust
nope
I don't trust shampoo that's for certain
why I never use it
yeah definitely don't trust you all
right Larry
let's do this oh oh oh he's shotgun no
can't do it
impossible why did I have fun why did I
have fun I knew I shouldn't have fun
like I said to myself I shouldn't have
fun
my legs my legs my leg ah my lack of
trust paid off never trust a towel
skeletal repair kit that my legs are
broken
I need that let me drop this but uh let
me drop this [ __ ]
for a second gonna gonna help me use it
hello wait hello wait look use it I need
my bones my bones are broke my bones are
so broke can you please fix my bones
alright fine they can't fix my bones no
bone fix okay okay no bone fix all right
fine then what was even the point of
coming in here dunk assist play ball oh
man but I got a dunk oh but I got a dunk
okay
fatal fortress did I just dunk on a
phantom
yeah oh did I just dunk on a phantom I
think I did holy [ __ ] okay all right
that was good huh okay let's keep moving
on let me take a sip of water
refreshing Oh delicious okay let's get
up to the shuttle then whoo um I didn't
turn on that music no please it's
probably the corruption level going up
that's bad okay I still got to get up to
the turret but I just haven't found the
way to go up yet or maybe I haven't I
haven't even looked at it probably that
one that's probably what it is
I don't want to go into these I want a
medical operator please oh my god good
thing I got somebody guns
oh no no no I hate this I hate this
anything it's I hate this okay shuttle
stop using global business signal for
not business okay I don't know if
there's gonna be anything in these but I
really need to find a medical operator
I'm thinking that maybe it might just be
best to go up huh huh don't trust you
okay just you know don't trust you
what's this that's nice huh hello you
were a towel you were gonna go be a
towel I bet uh no no my god
not not married you're not gonna take
marry for me you're not gonna uh okay
take off take some Steve where'd you go
where'd you go I know you're here so
Chris don't rush don't rush I didn't
trust it I shouldn't have trusted yeah
yeah Steve was all over your face Dave
was all over your face why did I trust
why I'll never trust I shouldn't have
trusted why did I trust you
there was no point in coming in here it
was just a surprise that I didn't need
uh I gotta hurry up the corruption level
is only gonna get higher and higher as
things go on
no no matching keycard I am losing blood
I am just leaking everywhere all right I
can't get in there
that's okay let me before I go to the
Ken Cup oh I have this never mind let me
go here okay all right you're up sleeve
whoo that's I'm gonna use that
okay space elevator don't care gin don't
care okay
nothing in there in their mimic log to
move fatal fortress not important okay
no I read that okay
you'd think there would be something in
here if it's gonna be wait why did I
need a key card to come in here if there
was nothing super important in here in
the first place
okay I don't know why director you don't
trust uh huh no way it's not gonna
happen not today not on me not on me
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
that on me I still need to get a
teleporter I need to get a teleporter
with with a recycler charge that is
something
oh thank you
burnt circuit board I don't need either
of those we're good trust nope nope okay
the suit I forgot about the whole suit
repair like that actually needs to be a
thing okay
anything in there oh those looked
important I probably shouldn't have just
yeah that seemed like they might have
been worth something Oh yep yeah I
should probably stop doing that but I'm
not gonna sorry Haley talus is awesome
giant cruise ship in space run aggress
ah opto regressive Narada me I don't
even understand what that word means
okay
there was something but it's nothing
okay can't get in their bathroom again I
love the bathroom
[Music]
we got another access panel here okay
I never thought I'd be running low on
bullets in this run but apparently I'm
I'm if I keep up the no trust my grundle
why why would you do that
but if I keep up the no trust I'm gonna
run out of bullets so I got to start
trusting again oh I'm back here ah I
didn't even know that was there
okay well that was a big wasted where am
I going
where oh wait oh oh here he's gonna hurt
oh okay all right that's not so bad I'm
learning to trust again
that watch I should have dressed it but
I killed something so it's all worth it
doo doo okay let's stay on let's see
what's out here
nope nope nope nope God today
it's hard to break the habit hard to
break that it very hard to break caviar
ooh yes please
actually I never had caviar but I'm
pretty sure I'd hate it never mod there
we go like that okay let's get some
repair maybe let's like you know repair
something that'd be that'd be cool if we
did that can we I'm concussed I can't do
it I got hit by a rock in the beginning
his goddamn game before all it's someone
[ __ ] back here Oh gross
yeah don't trust that
it's pretty that's real pretty
that's real pretty
so far so good good drama please help me
I am dying I am literally dying please
please I beg it I am dying help me I am
so in so much my legs are broken my head
is bleeding my brain is losing out
please just help me please I am begging
you if you could just help me that would
be great okay all right but that's fine
no Keith this is fine I don't need a cue
beam I don't want a cue beam recycler
fabrication plan okay that's good
okay all right buddy thank you for that
Oh we could take an ER amount down oh my
god this is perfect this is so good I'm
so happy now confirm let's blast that in
my brain and we're good to go
not today all right Steve you're back up
let's do as Steve you got this tram
station
we seem to be getting ever not closer to
the shuttle
oh wait because the shuttle was upstairs
that's right minute see you see you see
you are you okay alright I think we're
going the wrong way I think we need to
go back and then we need to go up those
stairs and that's gonna lead us to the
shuttle and then we can get out of here
because if we can finish this one then
that's good that's good oh hello Greg
hello Carol alright so that leads to the
habitation modules that I couldn't get
into so that's kind of nice oh you just
couldn't get that shotgun that's that's
unfortunate for you okay well I don't
need it you see this and that okay wait
you spy Typhon
another one of those good whatever that
is you guys don't look so good
you guys look real bad that way let me
use that actually ok security yes please
oh no password ok wait gonna hack it no
level 4 ok no no shotgun no need it
crew is anybody alive nope ok Pythias no
no one's gonna be alive why would anyone
be alive
ok area map good we actually get a map
maybe I should console my map
occasionally escape pod status check
status no escape pods ring that's
already out of here fire hazards no fire
hazards good there good good good good
ok good
tram status okay good we're good okay
was there anything else that this could
do not nothing here alright I think I
can't really take my time like I have
been because I realized if I want to get
through the next few alive I'm gonna
need to you know hurry hurry a little
longer I mean it's only gonna get harder
so is it really that bad why uh why is
everyone all happy this is so weird
hey you always wanted to get a good look
inside my head not like this when are
you going in I have your connectome I'm
headed there now to inject your piloting
skills into my skull you're right it
doesn't weird but at least now there
will be two shit-hot aviators who can
fly this Brickyard actually you'll be
obsolete cuz I'll be able to fix them
and fly them maybe you'll pick up some
of my other charming qualities yeah like
what I shouldn't have to tell you okay
alright
no three jammin tomatoes Sky King
pomegranates okay
that doesn't help all right so we need
to go we need to go get piloting skills
and we need to inject it into our brain
which is totally normal
very very absolutely normal so we got to
find where that lady was if I was paying
attention I would have gotten the name
but I didn't so whatever I want to
welcome our newest arrivals I'll be
blunt the moon is a harsh mistress what
was uh what was the name Angela yeah
let's do it let's do teamwork I love it
I love teamwork I love working as a team
team's cool teams are great all right
let's do this
we got a lot of more security cards to
so we can actually unlock some new areas
we just got a hurry up otherwise the
next Oh No
you're up there oh oh you're in the
farther area that's why oh that's why I
should go to the objective first and
then go where I see I explore like a
silly little [ __ ]
all the time and I don't know why but I
do it so I you know I shouldn't do that
but I do I'm just an idiot like that all
right let's go Angela your ass is grass
your brain is mine
where are you at Angela and Allie that's
not Angela whatever all right
mmm is anyone here no okay Angela oh oh
I got a request a trim ooh control
module I have one of those in my
inventory but what do they do like
what's the point of that I don't know
I'll find out later
nice DRAM Angela you in there doing
they're all Pythias laps that's right I
need to go over there all right so we're
going over the Pythia slabs I don't know
what's in the Pythia slabs but I'm gonna
get over there anyone else sick for
fallout 76 I kind of am I'm not like the
biggest fan of the Fallout series anyway
I never finished fallout 4 I never
finished fallout 3 I never finished New
Vegas like I always start it but just
like I never really get into it too much
yeah more gmod videos like yeah maybe I
always like just playing it for a little
bit it's fun oh look it's a fake me Wow
if it's not obvious that I don't do
giveaways and stuff like that or at
least my name is official just wanted to
take a second to call out Testaments
security commendation the commendation
goes to officer Casey Fletcher for
outstanding service be sure - yeah yeah
Casey Casey Security's so tight there
yeah oh yeah Casey Casey come on do it
do it whatever your name is
timber dude Oh
[Applause]
timber doodle
Timber duty Oh timber doodle come on
timber doodle you're a goddamn
disappointment disappointment stupid
jackass
alright fine timber doodle was no good
to anybody utilities are you map access
to the labs corruption levels about to
go up which I'm sure is going to be real
fun real real fun unlock escape pod
stash our and you know about that [ __ ]
don't have the password for that no
space for that let's eat these take
these read this great knowledge and eat
that ok can't go in here ok it's fine
ok moving we gotta go go go we are
running out of time
ah where am I going trauma center I
don't need it I don't think I can repair
that yeah what's the point of repair 1
if you can't actually repair anything
what's the point what's the point
I don't get it alright Angela where yeah
what do you got caviar that's what you
took how's your essential oh that's not
good that's probably very bad all right
so we got a hurry gotta get to Angela
where are you you're so far away
ok psychometrics no this place doesn't
look fun though you oh you know I'm
gonna drop this I don't I'm gonna drop
the banana peel Oh drop the banana peel
maybe maybe that's what I should drop
our Emma Tate
[Music]
okay you're not who I need but okay I
found a new friend who new friend here
[Music]
okay new I can't get in there that's
fine
oh that's that's what that's weird huh
what's the emergency this minute you
brought me something is definitely wrong
with it
it keeps throwing various shoes at me
are they nice shoes
I'm serious it's like it's punching
holes to somewhere a universe of shoes I
don't know but my point is someone with
sufficient - abilities and a strong
attachment to someplace else like it
like a place on earth yes exactly
then I think you could open a door maybe
even walk to it it might be more like
getting sucked through a very tiny tiny
straw I think I could tweak the
containment shield to stabilize the
mimic we need Riley's permission to run
this well what are you waiting for
I'll be in the lab huh and escape
through the mimic portal oh that's
that's that's cool all right but not why
I'm here Angela ooh I don't trust you oh
don't trust you so there's got to be
there's got to be something I should
have tossed my junk by the way I totally
forgot to toss my junk but that's fine
all right how do we know where are you
Angela Angela your three-year skate
ponds here yeah here
just drop these these die don't even
care ooh do I actually want them though
do I actually want them nope do I
actually want them dismantle I mean
that'd be nice suit modification there's
really nothing that I would need here I
mean yeah sure I'll take the dismantle
that just helps you with my inventory
now I can dismantle the [ __ ] here all
right how do i dismantle all right fine
nevermind it didn't work those total
weights for three neuro mods but it's
okay it's totally fine Angela Angela
Angela oh this oh this is this is the
escape pod Angela there she is you good
okay you're good Angela here's all I've
been trying to find you Angela you all
right Angela
all right fine then well
that I don't work that I'd do it god
damn man I just wait to drink during
buds Vermont fabrication plant ok at
least that's something
okay how do I didn't I get the dismantle
ability how do I do that
Oh equipment
okay let's just run I think we should
press okay report just gotta go for it
we need to get back we need to get back
we need to go back we need to get back
we're gonna get back we need to run okay
I'm not gonna hit him with my lightsaber
are you out of your mind you're out of
your gourd okay I need to fabricate a
neural mod and/or find one but I don't
know if I might be able to do that
because I Girma oh look
okay take that and put it over on top of
this stupid [ __ ] and take that put
it there okay normal we got it okay
piloting skill is loose goody out of
here let's get out we gotta go we gotta
run we're gonna run why am i radiated I
don't know we gotta go we're gonna go
we're gonna go we're gonna get out of
here let's get out of here let's go
well let's go dude sons of [ __ ]
always bothering me when I needed Oh
okay nice you're gonna blow up well
that's my church nevermind he already
blew up yep little I know there's other
secrets that I get get but I'm already
at corruption level three and that's
that's probably not good
that's probably probably extremely not
good ooh not today let's go - I was
right up by me those right I was ready
by me those right up behind me that was
rudder right by me okay so we got to get
over there you're gonna nail this we got
to get this in there and then just three
more characters to get out and I promise
I'm gonna go a little faster on them I
just don't have been with me so I said
why so many handguns why so many anger
why so uh yeah this is the exact reason
why dope I didn't reload thief oh no not
today not today good out luck hurt huh
this is exactly why not today
yeah you know that's good you
that's why that's why my god that is why
let's get you a tea we're good to go
[Music]
let me reload reload my gun okay I think
yep you would believe that huh
weird uh Oh where'd he go where did he
go up were you at he's up there
okay ready for a turret surprise he's
gonna blow up Wow Oh nonot weapon
malfunction not now no no no no you
[ __ ] different guns Oh Larry really
betrayed me on that one
Larry really let me down Larry let me
down on that one clear I'm not happy
about that you really let me down
Oh Larry let me down that's okay all is
forgiven
Larry cracked under the pressure I can't
really fault him for that but he wasn't
there when I needed it most
let's get a Yeti I seem to be burnt
we did it we did it we did it we did it
but there's two three more left to go
there's three more left if we want to
get out of here with everybody intact
which I don't think we're gonna do
bigger oh hey that's a whoa no please
don't
okay all right thank you we are reality
baby oh oh yeah oh yeah oh hell yeah oh
yes oh not you again
wait did I not wait what did I not what
did I not do not not
ah
mother pooper okay alright so what I
didn't do is I didn't I didn't know that
you needed to get certain things to
unlock the ah that makes more sense okay
so I got to go back in by myself well I
guess I'll go back in with her because I
already unlocked some of her abilities
so that might be fine
what is that escape pod navigation ship
what does that even mean yeah we're not
gonna try that we're gonna go in we're
gonna let's do just let's do just just
one pistol I know it sounds crazy but
I'm just gonna go in with one pistol
because I wanted to do this right get
some very much - all right that should
be more than enough we're gonna get
everything we need anyway please okay
crew member story bigger is now
available to you okay
alright we're doing this going back in
we have to go back in because we didn't
do it right
I want to unlock all of the other
characters stuff first and then we'll
get IATI we'll get a yachty after we get
everything going we got this we got this
we can do this we've wrecked it up we
[ __ ] it up real good
oh we're gonna get this I died yeah I
gotta go get the glue gun I deal with
with you know Gerry Larry Mary
Steve's believes Cleave Johansson Moe
Hansen Poe Hansen and Bob you know I
just really I really couldn't do a whole
lot of nothing there so we're gonna do
this right okay that's a new one ooh
multiple objectives that's nice alright
don't trust someone's in here I know
someone's in here come on all right
someone's in here
Oh Ben Ben oh my god it's Ben Oh Ben huh
oh okay Ben oh you were warning me you
were pointing right at you're pointing
right at it Ben
I can't believe it oh well this is um
we're off to up okay well you know I'm
gonna do a move here watch this move
pretty sick and AH there you go
Thank You Ben the Ben I can't take you
with me this time Ben I always I could
but I'm in a hurry and I'll only slow
you down
I'm sorry sorry all right we're gonna
leave Ben mine we can't bring bad we
can't we just don't have the capability
to do it we just can't do it this guy
okay
is this oh the moon man still here okay
so what I'm gonna do run away from the
moon
oh boy oh boy let's just you jump now
please okay we're gonna go back over
over over to here to where we were we
have I believe do we still have yeah we
still have the pallet piloting skills so
we keep everything that we we uh we got
from last time so we keep everything and
that's it uh hey bud okay we keep
everything that we got before so we need
to find we need to find some of the
crews that's like the world that we need
to find the crew first because we need
to find all we got to do is find a
corpse to be able to unlock one of them
and then then we got a complete story we
got to get these psycho scope which is I
don't know where that is why is this
closed off just show me a phantom that
phantom really that phantoms bugging you
[Music]
Oh
I don't wanna go please dude okay we're
fine okay we're fine we're fine
we're totally fine we're fine doing here
oh that's gross okay
door should be up and now yeah but it is
let me go through the doors let me go
through the door and then you're good
then you're good don't new son of a
[ __ ] you son of a B you like me you
worried babe no please dad he lured me
he lured me like a rocks are my one
weakness please do not
oh he's not happy
all right
just a simple moon shark that's a nor
normal everyday ordinary moon shark
everybody knows about him everybody's
seen him nothing to stress about so I'm
gonna wait until it goes farther away so
I can actually go through this door
which would be totally great okay good
good good good great I'm happy about
this so we're gonna go back in here
we're gonna look for a computer we're
gonna oh yeah that's right this is the
crew annex we're gonna go in here we're
gonna we're gonna get a computer and
then we're gonna we're gonna find the
security guard we're going to unlock
that guy and then we're gonna go get the
psycho scope from the top of the Pythias
lab I think they said the very top I
don't know where table would be but I'm
gonna go for that and then we'll see
what happens thank you got him
Oh got him oh god wait repair oh I can't
repair this finally okay that's good
to repair that um um nothing should be
different here so it should just be
phantom resurrection inhibitor I don't
even know what that means but it sounds
cool all right let's just get the junk
over
let's take one of these I don't know if
we're gonna need it but I'm gonna take
it and I'm gonna sneak through back here
but I can get behind them and then we
will see where this leads me okay
that was fun thank you for that I
thought we got the key card for that one
maybe this one nope apparently not okay
Wow Hey how you doing
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa okay he's dead Jesus guys
big oh I got a time slow that's nice
use that right away cool all right so we
need a computer where was a security
computer around here what's it upstairs
who's upstairs right upstairs
here's upstairs right believe those
upstairs yeah believe it was yeah pretty
sure was upstairs there was a Security
office up there
no no no no no back up - no Taif and -
no type in type and type in no type in -
no - so we're here this is good
ooh I'll take that now now I'll take it
I wasn't gonna take it before but I'll
take it now all right we got that this
that shotgun shells utilities we already
have the area map we just need to find
what was his name
what was his name what wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't him his name name vineya his
last name was vineya something vineya
[Music]
wasn't it wasn't it something like that
oh no oh no he's not here what was his
name what was the name you guys are or
his name right somebody remembers his
name start shouting out random names I'm
sure that'll help just keep keep the
names roll and so long as I get more
names I just need more names all I got
to do is get more names like just throw
names at me that's all I need if you
know his name don't tell me just smash
like button that's all it is but don't
bother saying words about it just just
hit that dingdong like button was it him
Oh
his first name was vineya last name was
Bhatia ah okay ah there he is
okay he's in the Pythia slap which is
good because the trams right over there
we can take it right over to the Pythias
lab I think I'll thunk oh I think he
thumb cool that there's um that the
psycho scope is gonna be over there as
well I
something Wagner I don't think it was
Wagner I'm pretty sure it wasn't Oh skew
I don't think it was Wagner okay good
let's call the tram and get you out of
here Oh what is that one it why oh god
oh god oh god why did I pick that up
why did I pick that up why why why why
did uh alright sit right back off I got
a goop sponge what back off the gun shut
up I'm a man with nothing to lose and a
real goopy Typhon thing I got a sack all
right okay cool great great mm-hmm yeah
I'm going for it
I'm probably not gonna be able to like
hundred put 100% this but I do kind of
want to see like what the general arc of
the story is because there is more
there's more to see from the the
perspective of the person on the moon
and I'm pretty sure that this corruption
is probably gonna probably gonna mean
something interesting as time goes on
we'll see if I can make this number
three four and this five why not why not
why not I have no idea where are you
Vijay what bro don't do that
my still just broke can I repair that
can I repair that I can't even repair it
I can't repair it maybe do I have enough
nod to get the second oh I don't it says
a good fiction it says I can how do I
fix you and just I wanna fix you do I
need it like a workbench or something
probably well this is bad okay well
we're in a whole hell of a lot of
trouble so I'm just gonna go through
here and see what sides go I'm gonna go
I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm going
I'll take that thank you very much we're
just gonna see what uh what we're doing
here oh it's completely freaking uses
okay great it was completely useless to
correct I'm so glad for that okay all
right to slide a slew all right we're
just gonna run for it we're gonna run
for it we're gonna make a run we're
gonna make a break for it we're breaking
for it oh I forgot I needed to open no
get away do it do it I'm going in this
room you can't come in this room -
where's a ow that hurt okay we're gonna
unlock that door I'm going okay goodbye
goodbye
yeah I know I have a shotgun I know I do
but I don't want it who did that's I
know I have a shotgun Wow Wow who who
and where and why
who dares strike me who and where and
why who are those minions those vary
minions tentacles inside me oh that
hurts a lot oh this is the worst thing
this is so bad please
I'm one shot the other one that one took
15 shots can't even loot it a bunch of
Garbo okay let me get my sweet sword
here that'd be nice
oh it's not open getting sweet sword you
go to number one now let's do this I am
hurting I'm hurting bed I thought this
yeah I thought that box might still have
neuromas in it but apparently not
oh well can't get lucky twice okay I did
not just use a medkit I thought I just
used one oh it doesn't go that much okay
price if it's where the escape pod is so
where's this dude's corpse Oh what where
is that where's echo how do I get over
there is it by the minions what Oh mmm
let me try this instead of the blade
just want to give it a shot oh my god oh
you don't sneak up on me like that
oh these guys love to sneak up on me oh
that looks oh no oh no oh no mod I need
I need four to be able to get no I
wouldn't matter anyway I can't repair it
okay
containment unit a well I'd I probably I
probably shouldn't probably shouldn't
release them well that looks nice weird
oh boy that that's no good there's
there's like people that are enslaved to
that thing and to be honest I can't
really help them at this point I know
that I could shock him but uh that seems
that seems like it's gonna be oh hey I
saw that
which one were ya okay I guess I can
just go for it
see how it works [ __ ]
science what it was a petri dish sample
I don't even want that and I millimeter
bullets doesn't make any difference
just tubing something in there I don't
know locker no I need I need to get a
fabrication thing because ooh fall into
yourself I don't know if I want to do
this but I'm gonna do it they don't seem
like okay alright you need permission
for number three all right well that's
weird
all right they don't seem like
volunteers they seem wooof a Typhon gate
oh boy yeah that seems that seems that
seems bad yep they seem dad seems like
prison yeah it's not volunteers that's
prison
okay great cool
yeah volunteer huh uh-huh
nothing volunteers oh hey buddy how you
how you doing don't look over here okay
thank you very helpful very good note
excellent note thank you for the help
that was so ill too far too fast okay
okay why why why why didn't mmm what the
BS
yeah stop what's up es that's nice hello
okay not that that what am I looking for
here something in here ooh nice guitar
sorry
okay Nura Mons that's nice okay at least
I can get the other repair thing which
would be nice I guess but I still don't
think I'm gonna be able to repair my so
don't think I'm gonna be able to repair
my gun yeah not on the fly
apparently not on the flight I wish you
could maybe if I actually pull it out
prepare it fire it malfunction no repair
okay no repair no repair for me no
repair today okay
no tax on let's go get our guy he's in a
room with a lot of unpleasant but uh you
know I said about Ben we don't leave
nobody behind oh there's definitely this
why is this such a special area okay
I'll take that cuz [ __ ] I can't take
that I got these control modules I don't
need control modules why do I have these
I'm gonna keep one but other than that
I'm not gonna take any you go Oh God
can I just what's isn't there yeah why
not a sword there we go okay you keep
nagging me that and okay I'm gonna try
to use the disruptor because that seems
like a responsible thing I could also
try the Typhon spore releases a cluster
of Typhon tentacles when dedicated
detonated can be thrown or attached to
surfaces that's that's nice that's real
nice
that's real nice okay that's real nice
let's do that I'm gonna die don't know
what this is gonna do but I'm gonna
throw you i'ma throw coop at you
hey bud how you doing um okay that's
weird okay all right i'ma throw coupe at
you you're gonna see you're gonna see
you're gonna you're not gonna like it
it's gonna get all in your hair you're
not gonna like it at all
you're gonna be like no I'm gonna throw
it at you is this person crater Oh
greater access Oh so I could have just
gone from the crater right to here oh
that's not open but this one is don't
worry guys I won't make your heads blow
up not gonna do that cuz I got a bag of
what's very likely to be pus and
everybody knows that's unpleasant that
is straight-up unpleasant so get ready
for a whole lot on Pleasant straight
from me all right I found it I got him I
got him I got him I found our boy okay
remember is now ready to play looks like
he didn't get too far
this is gonna be straight up with that
did you turn on me what did you turn on
me frickin pointless
oh great oh great wonderful elevation up
those pointless what was it what was the
reasoning for that what do they do
I didn't dick diddly I didn't dick
scutella dick Dawg I just did nothing
for me without minions again god damn it
okay so somewhere up I need to go up
because this is just a bunch of BS over
here just just through tentacles at me
why me and I'm just gonna go was that
rumba hey listen we don't need a whoa
hey oh [ __ ] yep no not you do uh-oh
let's get one shot out then ow
oh thank you thank you thank you
O'Reilly Ruth Riley you Riley use the
the one moonshining one of those hmm
this is Riley you this is the big boss
oh oh I don't have a password I can't
hack it either
well [ __ ] okay well that's a problem
maybe Riley use corpse has something
like that
not helpful not helpful at all what's
with those pictures that's weird
okay not helpful not helpful not helpful
Reap lawyer what does that even mean
dermal webs skin graft okay that was
something are you you're not you are you
know your McAllister
you friendly okay that's good to know
okay so now I've got two of the
characters unlocked which is good now
what I could do is I could just go ahead
and try to escape with this one yeah I
can go and I can go and just um alright
cool
I can go and just uh get out through the
shuttle but then again that removes an
option to escape from so I don't know if
you need to like collaboratively get
them together or anything like that but
if I had hacking ability I'd be able to
do that or if I I guess if I'm just
Riley you I would be able to do that
myself anyway conference room let's try
in here first hey buddy hey my buddy
both of these have error so I'm gonna
shock you oh never mind
City reloaded
boom and boy ball guy yeah now I know
how this works
oh yeah okay that was fun
glad I did that they sure learn their
lesson I hate these eels okay where's
this probably I don't know hello hello
the repair mechanic wasn't a thing in
the last game was it or in the original
game well some fancy schmancy bathroom
okay there was no point then okay Wow
all right I'm just gonna get a yachty
I'm gonna get iottie because then I can
carry on I can do whatever I need to do
oh okay nevermind you know what never
mind never mind
let me through please okay there's also
another there's another objective that I
need to accomplish but I I guess I could
go do that because I do need the story
mode there is a story objective I have
to shotgun you're right I do and I'm
gonna pretend like I knew that the whole
time and you're not giving me any new
information here I knew definitely I
absolutely definitely did know that yeah
there's a pattern to escape you planned
it out already well that does help that
does help I appreciate that thank you
for thank you for getting that thank you
I appreciate that
Casey collectors for outstanding service
the record the professor and Bible
oh that's Leslie drift
huh this is bad this is what you would
call bad hang on let me let me switch
out for
[Music]
okay he's gonna blow up and uh yeah he's
gonna goof all over the place but that's
fine oh this gets hard that's why I got
multiple pistols because the pistols
just constantly break on me they just
break all over the place I can't I can't
hear about the good news I can't hear
about anything nice happening I don't
think I put in any of my my actual my
chips I think I was just going mano a
mano and I was not having a fun time
about it these guys these guys are just
[ __ ] guys are constant [ __ ] I
think I gotta use the neuro whoa where
where where where you okay I think I
gotta use up all the neural mods before
I leave because I don't think you'd
carry neuro mods from one character to
another I think this is like neural mod
and then that's it okay so let me just
finally doodley doodle diddle diddle
diddle daddle II but diddily diddily
diddily Dumbo bottle d do p battle the
do P let's do that one one bottle D do
Dumbo okay that's good enough
let's get you a tea we're outie okay
yeah yeah I get it you're a dramatic
escape it mimics gonna be on the the
thing there and then we're gonna get you
out of you but it's gonna be fine and
then we're gonna go to the security
officer next and see if the security
officer can because the security officer
is required to get the last character oh
it's a mimic pose okay okay yeah yeah
there we go congratulations you escaped
I know okay we got alright yeah
that's nice that's nice okay not you you
you maybe nah nah security officer
because if you complete this guy's
escape with the security alfie using the
mass driver to unlock their story
objective oh wait oh I need to do I need
to do body it twice I need to do them
twice what's so special about this what
so special about Claire why does Claire
Nate Byars Claire so like hard to unlock
okay we're gonna go for it
we're gonna go for it we've got a
standard shotgun that's real nice but
you know I like a I'll like me a pistol
I like me the piece yeah we're gonna go
like three pistols we're gonna go three
pistols a hellstorm of bull and we're
gonna
okay if they break then we got backups
okay
and then we're gonna go for it okay we
got this we got this let's give them
some neuro mots - can you just oh my god
okay wait hang on back gee no not rista
there we go
okay and I delete one yes please death
then give me that okay cool all right so
we got that look through this let's do
this let's complete it we gotta just run
the mass driver sounds great cuz I think
that's just a giant gun in space and you
I get in and I strap myself to a bullet
and I just get shot like into space and
I'm like [ __ ] you Typhon I'm out of here
like that's that's probably what I'm
gonna need a rep and repair kit you need
a weapon repair yourself okay alright
you need you need weapons
yeah okay anyway right I need a weapon
repair kit okay now we're gonna go did
you finish case animatronics yeah a long
long long long long time ago long time
ago I didn't reset the simulation I
didn't want to reset the simulation up
I'm like doing this hardcore I am trying
to do this like I'm really good at this
game I'm really good really good I don't
know if you knew that but I'm pretty I
just like boosted that's so cool man
that's that's not good
let me get up here there's some there's
a corpse up here how did I do the boost
how do I do the boost
I like the boost how do I do the boost
oh this was not worth it Ben I'll
remember you ah double double double do
the double double Boylan trouble oh I
see okay all right
multiple objectives well which one is
what I've been doing escape through mass
driver let's do this one locked what do
I do it or do I not do it do I do it or
do I not do it I don't know if I do it
or not do I do it do I do it
okay I think I gotta do this
where's the mass drivers the question
right oh [ __ ] I forgot about mr. dude
way I like this this is fun but I'm not
gonna go to the same I'm gonna go to
where the multiple objectives are over
there Oh barb you better you better run
dude you you don't you don't know if you
slap I don't want to go there Oh
almost got you now where'd you go I just
so peered so I've already been the
Pythia slab the only place that I have
it doulas I haven't really gone
is moon works moon works that's right
Oh Jimmy Moon works give me those sweet
delicious moon works
oh hell yeah the moon works baby that's
where it probably is that's probably
where it is and there's where are the
Typhon you're not even gonna show me
okay great thank you
through the Typhon where are they show
Manny come on okay someday I'm gonna
kill that moon shark oh don't look at me
you're not look at me do not look at me
just get out leave you're not welcome
here so why would you even bother yeah
just go just go just go okay no it says
that there's still time fun but it may
just be the moon sure cool real
funkalicious all right seams open
okay I'm going I'm going I'm in okay
cool I don't know what the moon works is
all about but if there was on one place
where a mass driver would probably be
it'd be here all right
cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool
cool cool cool cool cool cool cool
okay yeah I'm not gonna go for too much
longer I'm probably gonna go for another
like 30 minutes or so and then like
that'll probably the end of this I I can
see like this is really cool DLC and
it's cool just because it's like it
offers like replayability but I don't
like the game that much to be able to
replay it so I'm just trying to like
like dig all the little little fragments
of story out like that's okay thank you
thank you for that handy-dandy update
appreciate that
appreciate you whoa what's that up there
I can't I wish I could go vertical on
this oh it's just a harvester destroyed
that's guy nice got some materials out
of it at least I don't know if I'm gonna
need know if I'm gonna need much here
there we go oh I got the bolts good the
foam bolts which probably like if I was
actually if I was actually using those
properly I would have um I would have
definitely used them as a distraction if
I was trying to be stealthy but I'm not
I go in guns all the time and that's all
I need
solo anyone needs really they're as good
as me
all right escape pod is over there at
this refinery is that where I need to go
wish I had a map I don't have a map for
this area
meep-meep
okay mass driver mass mass driver good I
miss just to make them scared
[Music]
moonquakes Oh moonquakes probably from
the moon shark oh yeah okay so is it
over there yes oh yeah that I definitely
need that it's getting closer
slow down time let's go come on
really one hit away one hit one head is
that what you're gonna do to me douche
all right no mass driver down here what
are you some kind of hidey hole didn't
work out too well for you yes it will
neither of us have been under that many
G's before I've calibrated the mass
driver to be within the human range of
Tolerance human range Jesus Jordan we're
not clowns in a circus cannon hey Harry
you cannot lose your [ __ ] on me right
now okay the shuttles gone escape pods
are effed this is our only shot we're
gonna climb into that crate and that gun
is gonna shoot our asses home and you're
gonna kiss your wife and your kids and
everything is gonna work out just fine
all right
all right yeah I'm good
good step 1 you have to get those
supplies loaded into the crate
you've got the shopping list yeah yeah
yeah I got it go the shopping lists the
I have to go shopping I have to I have
to go shopping shopping list 5 drinks
anything non-alcoholic 5 foods one
bottle of anti rabs
I see I see I see I gotta go shopping
[Applause]
whoo the walk oh you are you all right
ok so I got to get food oh that's silly
oh that's silly ok so but I can go to
the tram and I can go to the crew area
because there's a kitchen in the crew
and
you tried to sneak up on me now I'm
gonna work this time okay that's it
there's gotta be there's gotta be food
just somewhere here I gotta get
non-alcoholic drinks which is real nice
I don't know why booze wouldn't work
booze seems good but apparently booze
won't work okay
tram station just over here there's no
mess hall here right nope
okay so we got to go over to the hello
friend okay I could have gotten this
area's map if I just go on the tram
wouldn't I get to the if I just take the
tram everywhere wouldn't I get to the
Security office right away and then I'd
be able to get everything that I need to
get and then I wouldn't be a big dumb
Dookie do wish I am gonna be a big dumb
doofy do so I guess all right let's go
on the tram get over to the kitchen and
then we need some rad pills but I don't
know it's like I thought I would have
seen that every word looks weird I
thought I would have seen some like I
don't even think about picking him up
and it was part of the standard kit for
the other guys so didn't even think
about it
yeah great please have rad pills no
whammies itwe made me
[Music]
okay thank you gotta find some rad pills
that's gonna be the tricky that's gonna
be the tricky dicky here granik's that's
what we need
go go get get not so fast
I need to go faster best booze dehydrate
your fake booze dehydrates specifically
your face like specifically your face
gets dehydrated when you eat booze now
when you drink it when you eat it you
have to eat it absolutely what's this
game called it's it's praise moon crash
DLC so this was not part of the original
game the original game pray if you
haven't seen it yet I've did a
playthrough of it I put a link to the
plate could playlist in the description
down below so you can check that out if
you would like if you don't I will be so
unbelievably sad that I will cry myself
to sleep please anybody rad
does anybody rad enough dude or lady to
have some rad pills please oh you're
still there oh the dead ones that I that
I killed on the way to this shuttle
fancy all right so there's um if I go
down and there's a bunch of alcohol I go
down
that sounds bad oh my god
go away where'd you go I told you to go
anyway I see you through too busy
running away I don't like the rains fall
off on this seems like a lot seems like
more than it should be
whoop another time slow good wait these
like these higher quality wait are there
such things
there's such a things oh yeah that's
right oh that's right egg I got a
legendary sword oh they put rarity into
this Oh who's there someone getting
there fit on huh
someone lifting some heavy weights
alright whatever there I don't trust you
but I'm going to the cafeteria hopefully
there's some rad pills in here
where was the infirmary again there was
an infirmary around here somewhere I
just don't remember we're okay food
there we go
give give give no no no no ah anti rad
perfect okay glue cannon perfect give me
that Oh not enough space well yeah it's
[Music]
drop drop drop it's not like I'm gonna
be doing any crafting here I don't know
what the bone fix does but it doesn't
actually do anything for me so whatever
ah don't look at me like that Mary don't
don't give me that look I'm gonna take
your glue cannon I'm sorry I just you
know I need it for stuff and things okay
Thank You friends you got a glue okay
nothing I'm really I don't have any glue
with me so I don't have any actual like
glue glue
where was the that wasn't enough food so
there's got to be food like in these
people's like areas
Riley you know work hello no hello no
hello ah found one not you I'm not
looking at you
I'm not damaging you that guy damaged
you that was definitely not me okay duck
beer no can't get beer you're raising
waterfowl will be lame if food we need
drinks
you still need drinks surprise key card
for the storage room at the lounge so
rose water filled as the key card to the
storage in the lounge
what is that food take it where's drinks
oh wait there's a vending machine that's
right there's a vending machine there's
a vending machine with lots of give me
my gun who do you think you all know you
don't oh no you don't
oh you think you're gonna get away no no
you don't oh you thought you thought
you're gonna take my gun for me daddy's
just frickin rude rude to no end I can't
believe you are ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba what can we get rid of how about
this [ __ ] we don't need that okay
we're good we're good we got everything
we need we just need to take the tram
over again and then we are outie
we rowdy 5,000 and then
and whatever do we unlock the do we
unlock the other character do we unlock
the other character if we do that well
we're gonna find out no alien material
that's what you think moon works let's
do this let's get in a good gun let's
shoot ourselves it's like the reverse of
that old movie where you shoot yourself
to the moon blast yourself out of a
cannon then off you go into the wonders
of space into the wonders of space yes
I'm still playing yeah I fell asleep in
marks of yelling woke me up yeah that
sounds about right
do you know what BTS is or who yeah it's
that Korean Korean Korean acapella group
right there they do a lot of the they
dance I've seen him dance please file a
proper request so we can track supplies
and make everyone's life easier
was it over here yeah no yeah no no yeah
yeah no yeah this is it here we go we're
gonna blast off to the moon they said I
was crazy when I said I was going to the
moon but to be perfectly honest I I
already knew I was crazy but what they
didn't know is that I already drinks
alright we're good to go we're good to
go baby
[Music]
hello hello who's there where is that
where is massive all right we're going
for
hello where the hell are you weight was
huh I don't get it how do I get up there
how do I do that
how do I know how we get up there oh
there seems to be some like broken down
ramps and [ __ ] but I bet I bet I can
climb my way up there with this handy
dandy explody backpack maybe not wait
wait wait wait wait no no no no no
ignition not not not with oh you I
thought you were okay
Oh over here wait I see I see away okay
in here then maybe up there
okay here yeah okay there's gonna be a
good hope oh hello
what's that radiation not for me okay
we're up here now
getting up here loose oh nice crossbow
I'm sure that did you good when the
Typhon were breathing down your neck
okay now I have a glue gun but no glue
so this is just gonna hurt Wow okay oh
no thanks oh no what happened little
buddy what happened you get your ass
handed to you by someone who's way
better and more handsome than you okay
ah god damn it you're better than me
okay ah no no no no okay that's driver
access but mass driver controls
I'm confess old I'm confused I'm very
very confusing I have no idea where
you're taking me
oh I get it up this makes sense
all right now it makes sense now I get
it oh boy what do we have here
moonquakes
yeah we already knew about the moon
quakes can't get in there all right no
such luck for us we're just gonna we're
gonna gun for it I'm just gonna gun for
it I'm just gonna go oh it's through
there oh [ __ ] we can't gun for it we got
a killer
oh that's not good timing okay
come here you okay good now no Typhon
detected and we are good to go
let's get yet use neuromas good point
good point good point good point
neural mods we haven't even used them oh
we're just so good anyway we didn't need
them in the first place we're gonna get
this guy's gonna get piloting skills oh
leverage he'll lift heavy things oh hell
yeah
that combat focus I love it and that one
yeah love it I am there we go so
incredibly talented all right safety
protocols
oh yeah right safety protocols let's go
for it true cannot cancel this I'm aware
okay let's game oh I gotta go back to
the cargo container whoo okay we're
going for it holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] Grubbs it oh my god okay all right
whoa oh I didn't realize that was the
thing that we were gonna be doing today
okay okay we're in
we're in I'm in
hey not so bad I'm sure I'm not gonna be
liquefied in the goo Wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's hilarious that's hilarious that
is hilarious
that's hilarious that is hilarious okay
alright so we got a lot of that stuff
okay
finally we got another oh we got another
message oh yeah oh yeah okay all right
what do we got no nothing what do you
get
I'm 13 yes no one died it's like you're
just over a quarter of the way toward
the orders we sent you don't forget to
keep checking them you can see your
orders from the radio room or from
within the simulation itself everyone
here is very happy with your progress so
Orsi thought it appropriate to all the
rights of man from home and I sent it to
your workstation thank you
enjoy this slideshow of family my
daughter Oh Oh go to school oh oh is
that my wife oh nice flowers oh wow I am
motivated to keep working oh boy oh this
is nice daddy I love you we got new hose
and mommy says to say thank you my
friend lives next to us she is so nice I
miss you please come home soon
love tie last thing you should see two
new companion apps you can use next time
you're in the sim take a look in the
nura mod section of your transcript hope
you like them I gotta work on my kids
spelling because wow that's we got a new
house not a we got a new hose oh that
makes much more sense
she is sonís boy what is my wife
teaching that child because that is just
incorrect on every level okay all right
okay all right so we didn't quite get
what we wanted let me just I want to go
back in just see cuz I think it reset it
if I'm not mistaken I believe that
probably reset it and if it did then
that's good do not goodbye I don't know
if it's good or not I don't know what's
good and what's not
but we're only a quarter of the way
through okay all right so we would have
to icy we would have to reset it we
would have to do the security officers
story again to complete the story and
then we would still have to unlock this
one escape using the escape pod oh oh
you were supposed to go through the
mimic portal oh okay
well Roy Oh Roy okay so anyway that will
do it for now though I don't know if I'm
gonna come back to this game but I did
want to give the DLC a good try this was
a lot of fun oh did I go all the way to
menu I didn't mean to do that this was a
lot of fun it was really a lot of fun
and I liked that they made the DLC for
replayability because it allowed like it
allowed the the the player to get a lot
of content out of it like just from so
much stuff to explore it satisfied like
that itch it's got a little story to it
like in there that I like it's got like
some motivational things with the family
like emotional manipulation on the
behalf of them and then it's got like
this inner woven thing with a lot of
random stuff so it's really cool so for
$20 dlz that's pretty good like I think
that's pretty satisfactory I've already
gotten two and a half hours out of it
and I had fun the whole time and we got
to meet Ben and we got to name all the
guns and that was real fun so I'm gonna
I'm gonna duck out for now videos should
be coming back to normal very soon and I
will be going to VidCon very soon if you
didn't know I am going to Amsterdam in
July which is just next month if you
haven't gotten a ticket and you would
like to see us in person go to
delmarvalife.com and check out for
yourself we're also coming to Australia
and New Zealand in November so check out
toor dhal markiplier come for that as
well thank you everybody so much for
watching and let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and I
appreciate you guys being with me here
today and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye bye bye guys
thanks so much for being here thank you
everybody for being a part of this this
was super cool and more videos coming
bye bye